jerry shantow is an 11-time ncaa
all-american swimming champ and was at
both races today she joins me now
jerry um it seems like the announcer
really wanted to you know tell us all
how close everything was
um tell us what you thought of how
things unfolded
uh laura thank you for having me um it's
actually interesting when you um
introduced me earlier before this
segment came on you use the word
outraged
and what i felt watching
this morning and this evening was
genuine just devastation and sadness
for the women that are
being asked to show up
at
the women's ncaa division one swimming
and diving championships which is
possibly
the fastest meet in the world if not
certainly our country
and to then
under the best of circumstances perform
their best
go best times
and now you need to do it against a male
body
you need to do it and exit
the pool silently and gracefully
and then
i watch them get out and cry with their
coaches and their parents
because of the emotional and
psychological turmoil that is taking
on these women and that is what needs to
be said
that is what people need to hear it is
more than just the sport it is more than
losing the titles which they are
certainly losing
it is also the psychological
disruption that is happening to them and
the lack of support that the
universities and our ncaa is providing
them and it is
abhorrent to be a part of
um i even felt complicit sitting in the
stands
today and i think that that is why
i wanted to come on
and do anything that i could to help
move the needle and make sure that we
continue to support women
and fairness and protection in their
sport
and to be very clear that this is not
about hate
this is about protecting women in all
aspects
now
and
in the future
jerry i want to jump i want to jump in
and ask a question you were a backstroke
i believe all-american 100 and 200
backstroke um yes now let's say leah
thomas had
really trained in backstroke
let's say the last
two or three years
before the transition and then
the transition
and competed against you would your
would your i mean it's a hard question
hypothetical but
yeah it's not clear that
is it that you would have been an
all-american now you wouldn't maybe have
won as many championships as you did do
you ever think about that
i do all the time and it's not
hypothetical to the women that are
competing at this meet today in 2022. it
is not hypothetical it is not
theoretical it is happening i watched
girls on the scoreboard get ninth that
will never be able to call themselves
a top eight finalists at ncaa's i
watched women who got 17th today that
will never be able to call themselves an
all-american like i get to today because
i
was given a fair and equal opportunity
in my sport we grow up being told the
world isn't fair life isn't fair and
sport provides one of the very few
opportunities that we rely upon and that
is being taken away from them all of a
sudden
and
we are asking them to not only endure it
that's the bank sherry we gotta we gotta
roll but they're not allowed to speak
because if they do they'll be drummed
out of the university a double insult
jerry i want to thank you for your
bravery and speaking out as a former
high school and uh athlete myself and
thank you keep doing it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else